sens en bourgogne c'est ce qu'on a
choisi de faire de vendre et je pense
qu'on a fait durant le mandat qui
s'achève beaucoup de cris de mise en
valeur de cette île on n'a pas voulu en
faire on le veut dans ce troisième
ceinture parisienne ce que l'on veut en
faire c'est véritablement une terre
d'accueil avec la douceur de vivre ce
temps faites aux confins de deux régions
et c'est vrai que depuis depuis des
années et le pen a trouvé sa place
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est dans une sorte
de no man's land entre l'île de france
elle a bénéficié d'une proximité mais
qui n'est pas exploité du tout qui n'est
pas exploité puisque les élus en place
depuis trop d'années d'ailleurs on quant
aux naissances bat dans ce dans ce no
man's land
vous avez plus de 5000 navetteurs et par
exemple la dernière crise sanitaire avec
le pôle iiid a mis en évidence que ces
navettes heures va se sont orientés vers
le télétravail donc donc c'est plutôt
une chose pendant considération et
notamment il est important de développer
les espaces de coworking ci a de vraies
opportunités avec nos gants paris avec
la région parisienne d'autres villes
vont chasser dans la région par rapport
à la qualité de l'eau et des sols ont
fourni paris en haut il ya des accords à
trouver pour l'été à maintenir une
qualité de l'eau intéressante la
production bio et puis des partenariats
à travailler avec la région dont
notamment sur tous les domaines où elle
est compétente et transport